-My next guest is
the Oscar-nominated star
of "Goodfellas"
and the Emmy-nominated star
of "The Sopranos."
She is awesome.
She now has an awesome new show
for HGTV called
"My Big Italian Adventure,"
and I think it's the best idea.
It airs its finale
this Friday at 9:00 p.m.
Here is Lorraine Bracco.
Lorraine, look at you.
You look great, buddy.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
I appreciate this.
-I love coming on your show,
Jimmy.
It's always fun.
-I heard that you're in Memphis
now working a new movie,
is that right?
-Yep. I am in Memphis, and I
went to Graceland yesterday.
-I've never been. How was it?
-It was on my bucket list.
-Me too.
-Oh, my God.
-I love Elvis.
-You got to get Dee Dee
to give you --
She gave me a private tour.
-Dee Dee.
-She was phenomenal.
-Did you just --
I'm freaking out. I love Elvis.
-She told me
so many great stories.
One of the great stories that
I loved was Bruce Springsteen,
when he was starting out,
he climbed over the wall,
and security went and got him,
and he said,
"Look, I'm Bruce Springsteen.
I'm a singer."
Yeah, like,
"No, you're out of here."
-[ Laughs ] It's like not yet,
you're not Bruce Springsteen.
-Yeah. Exactly.
-You're almost
Bruce Springsteen.
Yeah, get out of here.
Yeah, this is Elvis' house.
But wait, did you see
the Jungle Room and everything?
-Everything, everything!
-Ah.
-It was phenomenal.
Jimmy, it is so worth
everything.
I mean, look, if you love Elvis,
forget it.
-I love Elvis.
-Which I do.
Did you see my new shirt?
-I mean, I was looking at that.
I said, "Oh, my goodness,
come on."
That is gorgeous!
-I love it.
I want to talk to you
about so many things.
about the show.
I think it's perfect.
I think you set it up perfectly.
It's perfect on brand for you.
'Cause I see you and honestly,
I go right to "Goodfellas"
or I go to "Sopranos"
and I go, "Oh, my gosh."
You must be like, "Yeah, I know.
Yeah, I was in 'The Sopranos.'
Yes, I was in 'Goodfellas.'"
But you were
in two legendary things.
I mean --
-I was lucky.
-Ah, no way.
Have you --
Do you ever watch your stuff?
Or are you an actor
that doesn't watch their work?
-I don't really watch my stuff.
But I know a lot of people --
I know it was like the 30th year
of "Goodfellas,"
which I can't even believe
because I still feel
like I'm 12.
But one of the things I did do
was I saw the film
in its entirety at
the Hollywood Forever Cemetery.
-Oh, I've never been there!
I've heard about that.
-That's another bucket list.
I'm going through my bucket list
really quickly.
Jimmy, you got to get --
-It's like a drive-in, right?
Or a picnic or something?
-No.
It's a picnic,
and there were 4,000 people
that came to watch "Goodfellas."
It was a full moon, and I
watched it with an audience,
which is what I had
always wanted to do.
-Did anyone know you were there?
-The people knew,
you know, who run
the Hollywood Cemetery thing
knew me.
But no, no, I did.
I gave a little speech
in the beginning,
and people were, like, crazy.
-See, come on, that's what
it's all about, right?
I mean, I don't know.
I think of you.
You know how many people,
like -- even when I make
Italian food, I'll throw on
"Goodfellas" or just --
It just gets me in the mood,
and you go, "Yeah."
So that's when I heard about
your show.
I go, "Oh, this is
the most genius idea."
Explain to me how you heard
about this house for sale.
-So, my phone, I get those
alerts and CNN writes, you know,
buy a 1-euro house in Sicily.
And I'm like, "Yeah, okay."
-Yeah.
-You know, let me sell you
a bridge, okay?
So I press on it and I read all
about the mayor and the town
and the people, and, you know,
how they need to revitalize
this town and that they have
some houses.
I just thought --
I went to sleep and I got up
the next morning and I said,
"You know, this is a great show
for HGTV."
-Yep.
-"This is a good idea."
They said, "Lorraine, if you
want to do it, it's yours."
And I was thinking more of
maybe it could be something
I could produce for somebody.
-Yeah, you go,
"Wait, I don't have to be in it.
I have to do the renovating."
-I wasn't thinking about me.
So the fun part about it was is
they were so cool.
They said, "Listen, we're going
to send you over.
If you love it, we'll do it.
If you don't love it, meh, meh.
We'll let it go."
-Yeah.
-So, of course, I go over,
and my first vision of the town
is this gorgeous hillside, and I
look out, and there's rolling,
beautiful wheat fields
and vineyards and olive groves.
And then I see the shepherd with
his 100 sheep cross the road.
-I mean, I'm weeping.
I'm weeping already.
-[ Laughs ]
-Sold!
-And I started to laugh.
I said, "Oh, my God,
this could only happen to me.
This is fantastic."
-It seems too good to be true.
You go, one euro,
which is, like $1.
You bought a house in Sicily.
But then you get there
and how is the place?
-It's a [bleep]hole.
-[ Laughs ]
It's a disaster!
-It's worse than that.
It's a dirt floor.
It's caving-in rock walls
that are, you know,
huge and enormous.
You can't move them.
There's no roof.
That's not true.
There was a roof.
It was bamboo.
Bamboo and a couple of leaves.
-Oh, my God,
you're like, one euro.
Now you owe them money
from buying the place.
-There's no plumbing,
no electricity.
Yeah, there was --
it was a [bleep]hole.
-But you -- Well, you have to
watch the show to watch it,
"My Big Italian Adventure,"
but you got to work with
great people and all the locals
and all that stuff, correct?
-Oh, it was magnificent.
I mean, I don't think you could
really build a house like this
here without costing literally
millions of dollars.
-Wow.
-Everything -- Everything was
reclaimed, all the doors,
all the windows.
-Ah!
-They carved out sinks for me.
I have beautiful stone sinks.
You can't imagine.
It's to die for.
-As soon as quarantine is done,
you know I have to
stop around there.
I will be calling you, please.
-Come on. Come on.
-Who is the guy that helped you
out, the contractor, was it?
-Piero.
Now, Piero, he knows our show?
-He loves you.
-Piero, if you're watching,
buona sera.
[ Italian accent ]
It's me, Jimmy Fallon.
[ Normal voice ] Your work is
bellissimo, magnifico.
Grazie mille.
Is that okay?
-Oh, my God. Yes.
And what you should ask him is
when you want to make your house
over there,
you're going to need him.
-Can you lend me a euro?
[ Laughter ]
-No problem.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Lorraine Bracco
in "My Big Italian Adventure."
Take a look at this.
-I can't move this,
so we're going to build a block.
Like, we'll build around it,
on top of it and make a --
What do you call that?
A, uh...
-The sink.
-Something solid?
-No sinks.
-Uh, uh, uh...
Is it bigger than a bread box?
-Sounds like...
-Yeah, one word.
-Yes.
-Storage?
-No storage.
-A cabinet?
-A countertop.
-Countertop. I'm so sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-Lorraine Bracco, everybody.
Check out the finale of
"My Big Italian Adventure"
this Friday at 9:00 p.m.
on HGTV.